نعم خالد بعباره ميسي وين وين لا زالت
الجماهير هنا في شوارع الرياض تحتفل بهذا
الفوز الكبير الذي حققه المنتخب السعودي
الذي بدا بروح منافسه عاليه في هذه
المباراه التي خالفت جميع التوقعات كما
نشاهد الان ااه الاحتفالات في الشوارع
التي
بعد انتهاء المباراه بنحو ساعه لا تزالت
لا تزال الفرحه تعم الشوارع هنا والفرحه
بالمنتخب السعودي الذي حقق فوز كبير وغير
متوقع والذي كان الدافع الاول له همم وفقا
لما يقوله الجماهير المشاهدين المباراه
هنا بان استقبال ولي العهد الامير محمد بن
سلمان للاعبي المنتخب قبل التوجه الى قطر
وتوجيه لهم عباره العبوا دمتعوا لا نتوقع
همم النتائج كبيره امامكم منافسه كبيره
جميع هذه العبارات ساهمت بتفوق المنتخب
خلال همم مباراه مع الارجنتين التي يلعب
فيها ميسي والذي كانت تخوف الاكبر منه
ناخذ راي بعض الجماهير المتواجدين الان عن
توقعات همم بهذا الفوز مع الان اهلا وسهلا
بك متوقع الفوز هذا ايه والله يتوقعنا
معكم اخوكم من اليمن نبارك ونهني للشعب
السعودي بمناسبه فوزه فقد افرح المملكه
العربيه السعوديه وقد افرح الدول العربيه
كامل
المنتخب السوري
المباراه
للعالم كله يحيا العرب تحيا السعوديه
شكرا اذا كما تشاهد خالد هذه المشاعر همم
النابعه من الفرحه التي تمت من هذا المكان
من شاشه عملاقه وفرتها امانه منطقه الرياض
اتاحت للمشاهده المباراه المنتخب السعودي
للجميع والاستمتاع بالفوز الغير متوقع في
هذا اليوم المختلف نعم